ل المتابعه معنا الان من رفح مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام نجمل معك طبعا
التطورات الميدانيه والانسانيه في القطاع
تفضل هي التطورات دائما هي ما تكون
استمرار للقصف الاسرائيلي خاصه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال متوغل في خانيونس القصف
الاعنف هو الذي تشهده مدينه خانيونس وهو
القصف الاكثر كثافه خاصه في ظل استمرار
العمليه البريه القوات الاسرائيليه مازالت
تحاصر مناطق مختلفه في المناطق الغربيه
لخان يونس في قلب مدينه خانيونس وكل هذه
المناطق باتت تتعرض الى القصف العنيف
والاكثر كثافه في محافظات قطاع غزه القصف
ما زال مستمر على مدينه خانيونس استمرار
لاطلاق النار لكن الاخطر من كل ذلك ان
عيون الصحفيين ليست موجوده هناك بسبب
استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي بسبب منع الجيش
الاسرائيلي للصحفيين من التحرك بسبب منع
طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني من
الوصول الى انتشال الجثامين وايضا ايض
اجلاء المصابين في اكثر من منطقه واكثر من
محور القصف الاكثر عنفا خلال صباح هذا
اليوم والليله الماضيه هو الذي
شهدته منطقه مستشفى ناصر هذه المنطقه هي
التي تتعرض الى القصف الاعنف في مدينه
خانيونس رغم ان القصف في كل المناطق عنيف
لكن القصف مركز على تلك المنطقه البوابه
الشرقيه لمجمع ناصر الطبي تعرضت الى قصف
عنيف المدارس في تلك المنطقه المنازل في
تلك المنطقه تعرضت الى التدمير تسمع ما
بين فنه واخرى اصوات انفجارات ناجمه عن
قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي ومواصلته لقصف
واطلاق القذائف المدفعيه في تلك المناطق
في خانيونس المنطقه الاخرى
الاكثر ربما الاكثر قصفا ايضا هي منطقه
التدريب التابعه لوكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الانرو وهي منطقه يطلق عليها
الفلسطينيون هنا منطقه صناعه الوكاله وهذه
المنطقه يتركز القصف الاسرائيلي فيها رغم
ان هذا المركز ربما هو واحد من اكبر
المراكز التابعه للاونروا مراكز النازحين
ولجا اليه النازحون منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه بعدما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان مناطق المواصي والمناطق الغربيه لخان
يونس هي مناطق امنه الان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقصف تلك المنطقه يركز قصفه واستهدافه
لهذا المركز وبالتالي هناك اداد من
الاصابات تصل في كل لحظه وفي كل حين الى
المستشفيات لكن المستشفى الذي تصل اليه
الاصابات من خانيونس هو مستشفى ابو يوسف
النجار في رفح ولكن ان تتخيلي المسافه
التي يقطعها وتقطعها طواقم الاسعاف من اجل
الوصول من المناطق الغربيه لخان يونس عبر
طرق التفاف للوصول الى هذه المنطقه في رفح
في المناطق الشرقيه وهذا بالتاكيد ياخذ
وقتا طويلا وبالتالي يعرض حياه المصابين
الى الخطر الكبير من جراء عمليه الاصابات
وايضا بطء عمليه الوصول في ظل الاكتضاض
السكاني في مدينه رفق وبالتالي الق القصف
الاسرائيلي في مدينه خانيونس ما زال مستمر
45 اصابه وصلت بحسب المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه من منطقه الصناعه فقط
ومن بينهم 15 اصابه خطيره بفعل استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي واطلاق النار على
المواطنين الفلسطينيين في مدينه خانيونس
بالتالي هي عمليات قصف مستمره مدينه رفح
ايضا تعرضت الى القصف فجر هذا اليوم
واستهدفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
منزلا هناك شهيدين من جراء ه القصف لهذا
المنزل عندما نتحدث عن رفح نحن نتحدث عن
المدينه ربما الاكثر اضاضا والاكثر كثافه
سكانيه في العالم وبالتالي اي قصف
اسرائيلي يحدث شهداء وجرحى بالعشرات كان
هناك ايضا قصف خلال ساعات مساء امس ايضا
في حي التنور في رفح لمسجد واستشهد اكثر
من عره فلسطينيين من جراء هذا الاستهداف
وهناك عشرات الاصابات وبالتالي الضغط الان
الاكبر والتحدي الاكبر على مدينه رفح من
اجل استقبال النازحين من خانيونس من اجل
توفير المستلزمات والماوي والفراش
والاغذيه والماء وكل هذا غير متوفر وهو
شحيح للغايه في مدينه رفح البنى التحتيه
لم تعد تحتمل كل هذه الظروف وكل هذا العدد
الكبير والاخطر من كل ذلك ان مستشفيات رفح
الان مجبره ومضطره على استقبال هذه
الاصابات من مدينه خان يونس لا سما وانها
مستشفيات صغيره لا تستطيع استيعاب اعداد
كبيره لا يوجد فيها غرف عمليات ولا غرف
عنايه مكثفه وبالتالي مناداه رفح كانت على
مدار السنوات الماضيه انهم يريدون مستشفى
في رفح لكن رغم كل هذه الظروف لم يتوفر
لهم المستشفى والان رفح مضطره بطباعها
وممرضا وطواقمها ان تستقبل هذه الاصابات
وتتعامل معها في ظل ظروف صعبه في ظل نقص
من في المستلزمات وفي الادويه وفي كل
الظروف وفي الاسره وفي كل الاحتياجات
الخاصه بالقطاع الصحي في رفح شكرا جزيلا
لك من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشم زقط